[Music]
there was a collab
with jojo siwa it ended up being her
kind of outing and it kind of like
fall out at first because i mean i
personally didn't know we all talked
about it
we didn't know that she had a girlfriend
so i texted her and
i was like do you want ken to take down
the video i'm so sorry what
that you got affiliated with us like
that and then she's just like honestly i
do have a girlfriend
and i wanted to come out i just didn't
know how what do you think
jojo's coming out will do for the youth
of the queer community
as weird and cliche as it may sound
it made being gay okay i'm excited to
see how these kids kind of take this and
run like
and just finally just be free what is
pride house la all about and where did
the idea come from
white house la is what most people think
is just a content house
but it's so much more than that we
decided to
create this house that we could um help
the youth with we were really inspired
by our youth and
wanted to be a house that had a mission
rather than you know
just uh visibly you know attractive
swipe ups you know so and i feel like
when you go to our page you feel safe
we're hoping people feel safe safe space
a safe space to
either come out or feel like there's
people like you or
allies that we have tough conversations
within our
our community and each other yeah you've
had some incredible collabs so far
with pride house la each of you tell me
who a
dream collab would be i
love lizzo i was thinking too i think
lizzo's tik tok is
my favorite she's got something to say
and she's not afraid baby and i
i'm on board with that she's an ally 100
and she's
i love um high school musical and i love
vanessa hudgens and i want to
i mean i want to collab with her i think
her energy her being who she is
how she like portrays herself she's such
a again she's an ally and
and just a really cool person i i feel
like it would be awesome to kind of get
her on board and
see her uh move her move and dance she's
she can move
oh she can move i would say ellen i
would love to climb
ellen degeneres yeah yes
she's one of the one that paved the way
uh paved the way for us and i
would love to have that conversation i
would definitely love to collaborate
with this person but i just want to be
friends with them
elliott paige yeah oh my god i mean
canadian canadian and we love aliens
yeah we just have a major collab where
all these people hang out with us would
you say that
a platform like tick tock is a safe
space
for queer youth i think it can be a safe
space i think just like any app
there's a dark side to you know all of
these social media platforms and
we've recognized that there wasn't a
queer
content house and letting people know
that you can express yourself in
whatever way
makes you feel confident and comfortable
and that kind of authenticity is what's
important
for these kids to see is that as they
grow up it's not about
the gender identified clothing you're
wearing it's wearing something that
makes you feel confident and it's you
expressing yourself the way that makes
you happy happy pride
cheers for your search queers